hello and welcome to this video
Grandmaster Mara anguish no name okay
yeah let's go forums oh yeah it's them
mainline IAM hmm how is this plate I've
had this on the board oh it's being
unsure about the precise water
Oh what do I play a rook to d1 may be
here always feel like black equalizers
here I think I have to have to check
this line I saw this line with Quincy
two and then castles our Father sorry
castles 593 this one recommended in a
video by Ann Gustafson and I kind of
liked the positions but I have forgotten
most of it I just watched the video once
and adopted this for my blitz games but
I have forgotten most of the detail so
it's something that I definitely need to
refresh my memory in yeah just 94 should
be okay for black hair right only way he
actually cannot play that up so I'm
sorry like an edge instead just take
well takes Bishop takes maybe uh huh
interesting
a three-year Bishop takes Bishop takes
bishop you for good I don't want to play
a three-year it's really not a more I
like to claim then it's just support see
for a little bit
yeah maybe I'm a little bit more
comfortable yeah I don't really don't
really know he still has to worry a
little bit about that d pawn in some
situations not not often that but if he
trades in though in some but it's
interesting yeah I was thinking about
this he just takes them or just accepts
the IQ p.m. no I just overlooked this
move oh my god I should think about it
mine was a little bit ah
great great immediately last chance not
not funny not in playable a little bit
on maybe d6 maybe d6 is also possible
okay let's let's try that I get two
minor pieces at least still not great
this 47 maybe maybe g7
Wow very bad i didn't see my dear idol
check
I'm getting 22 pieces to minus which is
not enough but well he I'm threatening
push-up g5 a little bit hmm and that can
probably play Bishop takes f3
hmm I wonder sesam some fired left here
I mean not objectively I know that of
course but 94 maybe I cable will take on
g2 yeah maybe still then put the night
on b5
you should see one root be one less
special g5g five mmm isn't that a move
you can't let's play that it's lost
anyway so why not I can just take this
I'm just needed oh wow right reason got
an off game didn't see anything at all
yeah wow yeah cd5 just just amazing Kim
leather suit off game didn't see
anything 995 is what I have to do this
is not blundering stuff probably equal
charity I'm just lost check I can play
knight c6 and win here that's nice this
was just a terrible game from start to
finish I had the feeling that something
is off here for black because that looks
strange somehow I was thinking it has to
go back and this is in fact winning for
white
never came up in that move cd5 deserves
deserves to lose the game I just didn't
see anything here in this case it was
just downright terrible ah yeah but
they're those games exist those games
exists what can you do thanks for
watching